[Music]
good evening hello and welcome to
scitrek and sorry about my background
it's going all crazy and blurry but i
can't get the light tonight so
sod it
i am going live this evening as a lot of
you know already
because last night while i was sleeping
snoring get my head off my wife said um
we hit 10 000 subscribers which is
phenomenal i was live last night we were
talking about it we was hoping maybe we
might go live you know 10 000 while we
were actually on
and it is party time shelly i have
my drink every time i say basically i'm
taking the swig goddess the camera
tonight is the green screen tonight it's
going crazy sorry about it guys
let's change the times woohoo
stephanie thank you alan thank you
it's very cool
so i thought i'd come on
and i would actually tell you a bit
about why i started the channel how it
got to this point um it's only actually
been 10 months so we're averaging a
thousand subscribers a month which is
mental
um but i thought i'd tell you a bit
about why i started the channel and and
and how we got to this point because
just you know for fun and then we'll
mention people as they go through
um angela got it thank you so much matt
congratulations thank you sir you are
one of the reasons why we got to 10 000
matt so again i'm gonna i'm also going
to thank a few people and i've already
do that towards the end of the video
um so i'll tell you how it started
i was in the pub
four years ago now with my mate and we
were talking about um another friend
actually that has started a youtube
channel hiking and stuff
um and he loved it he just loved to give
him something to do um and at the time i
was actually going through a really
crappy time in my life um i was
going to
i was just awful and um and my job at
the time also meant i had quite a long
time because i used to work quite late
and so i was on the hot on my own during
the day quite a lot so i needed
something to distract myself so we're
talking and chatting and he says we
should do you know let's do let's do
youtube channel ourselves so we started
a youtube channel called the brief
history mystery
after three years
three years we had 1800 subscribers and
i was scrapping
scrapping to get even those
i am sharing everywhere and just i was
just on my phone constantly sharing
messaging people just you know like that
but learning the trade i'd never even
looked at youtube before uh or barely
before we started a youtube channel so
it was very much learning on the job
but through that i got to meet some
amazing people one of whom you know uh
resident american stormy bear i met him
through the channel um he just commented
on one of my videos i calmed down here
we have there we side chat
and then also i i met my good friends at
aliens and stuff and spencer mike um who
are just just really good lads down in
cornwall they got a brilliant channel as
well
um and we were chatting one day and we
just would say you know what they they
actually started talking about how they
what they wanted to do a star trek video
and i was just like i'd love to do a
sci-fi channel sci-fi is my passion i
love anything sci-fi um i'd love to do
that so we were going to do it together
we were going to do as a you know as a
threesome
um
but
we can you know they they live in
cornwall i live here stormy lives in
america so you know a couple of months
went by and i thought you know what i'm
just gonna do it
um i smashed around a few ideas and then
i came up with this psy trek
you know name um just
you know star trek and sci-fi and you
know it's not it's not rocket science
really where i came the name um i then
found out that there's actually a side
trekking museum in america but it's
closed so i'm reckoning i think i'm safe
with a copyright if the place is shut um
i still haven't said basically it but
i'm thirsty i'm going rum and coke this
evening by the way
um so
i thought you know what i saw i got
started
and then i did a couple of videos and
amazingly they did all right
i then did my first stargate video which
turned out to be not true because it was
based on a um giant freaking robot story
which actually actually turned out to be
true but anyway at the time i believe
wasn't true but it got like a hundred
thousand views
and which is just nuts and i went from
um nothing to a thousand subscribers and
being able to monetize the channel
something that took me two and a half
years when i had a brief history mystery
um in six weeks
which was just like saying just mental
and i've had spencer on the show we've
had mike on the show he did the quiz
they did the sci-fi quiz turned out he
never watches sci-fi he knows a bit
about stargate but other than that oh no
star trek he knew a bit about star trek
other than that he just spent the whole
evening going don't watch that it's just
that battlestar galactica don't watch it
anyway um so and obviously we have
stormy most sundays he still comes on
the channel now which is just you know
fantastic um
but off that hundred thousand view video
i got a few comments off people and i
started speaking to to these guys and
found out and actually some of them work
at mgm and then after that it was just
it was just fun i actually started
getting
reasonably good
intelligence from inside mgm that's
really helped me get the channel off the
ground and go from just you know a few
hundred subscribers to ten thousand
within ten months which is just
brilliant
um
you know
the nice thing is this is a hobby for me
i've
really battled getting sound right i've
got a nice new speaker now a nice new
microphone now but i if you go back and
have a look at some of my early videos
the sound is awful
um i got spent a lot of money and bought
a new camera but i was able to do that
from like the youtube views because you
know i actually earn a little bit of
money it's not the thousands right ramp
i i didn't get a message a couple weeks
ago
can you quit your job like no
not even close it's a nice little bit of
money that like from a hobby because no
hobbies don't pay do they most hobbies
cost you money so it's a nice little bit
of money i do get from youtube in the
advertising but it's not nothing like
enough that i can i was hoping to go
down four days a week but that doesn't
look like it's gonna happen either um
but but yeah so
you know it's it's a nice little little
bit of income as well which is nice
um but i was able to buy the camera able
to buy my new microphone able to do a
few other things karma thank you so much
so forget the power of stargate fans
um the nice thing about that is stargate
is genuinely honestly hand on my heart
my favorite show sg1 is my favorite show
i just want to say basically just don't
take a drink
can you think don't tell i'm excited by
the
way
and i'm hoping you've all got a drink
back there get in the chat if you've got
a drink with me if you're having a
little drink with me on friday evening
it's been a very very hot day here in
the uk and if you're from anywhere else
in the world let us know what it's been
like there but it's been in the 30s
today so we're all a little dehydrated
so um rum and coke
but um
i was talking about
but yeah so
i got the sound sorted
i bought two or three microphones in the
end i bought a lapel microphone that was
useless um i bought um i was into buying
this new camera that came with a
microphone that was useless so i had to
actually then fork out the the
microphone that's mounted to the camera
and that actually cost more
than the um camera did
and but then i've had to buy two laptops
i've got one laptop i use for editing
the video so on a tuesday and thursday
at 6 p.m here in the uk i release um the
recorded videos and they have to be
edited on one laptop because that's
powerful that that's good at doing that
but then i've it was never powerful
enough to do the lives
and so i used to have to do the
livestream my phone i never liked doing
it
and so i am
i is very grown up angela weldon yes
have a coffee i'm hoping you're not in
the uk though because it's very late
here for um the uk
jack thank you very much that is 86.
yeah i'm gonna take you away for that
week i have no idea when it comes to
fahrenheit but um but yeah we got up to
33.
um it's saturday morning here in
australia stephanie thank you for tuning
in that that is another thing i
absolutely adore about having and this
youtube channel and that it's i get
messages from people in australia and
um south africa america about half my
views are in america which is just
amazing i actually joke on my mates i'm
actually famous in america
nobody's ever recognized me in real life
um but if i go to america i'm assuming
it's gonna be like when the beatles
landed and everybody was like ah sci-fi
trigger um i assume that's what it's
gonna be like um
probably not
and but i absolutely adore that i've how
many hobbies can you do when you
actually make friends literally all over
the world stormy
who i now genuinely considered to be a
personal friend and lives in california
and if ever i go there you know i'm
actually going to america next year but
i'm hoping to go the year after go to
vegas and stuff um
you know
i'm assuming he'll let me stay there um
get into the comments stormy if you're
about
trick is bigger than jesus
come on um
i am
i i'm a little bit disappointed in that
stephanie that you are again though it's
not time for drinking alcohol you're
australian
um this is what i was saying salt you
sort your own your fans um your viewers
um but but yeah um
surely i think she you should crack a
beer open any time
and i will be drinking faster but i
don't think i'll be getting drunk
but whoop america in the house
the americans are some of the most
passionate people but um i do enjoy
shouting say aluminum sally minion
stormy i do i do quite enjoy poke in
front of him 509 pm on a friday night
here in bristol tennessee
seeing panther pickle i just love that
that is
that that is what i love most about this
is look cal florida
38 degrees in florida and 90 humidity
oh kill me i couldn't i met i couldn't
do that
how do you even survive that yeah i
assume you've got aircon please tell me
you've got aircon
um
you know we're melting here we've had
one day of it we've got rain tomorrow so
it's going to cool down a lot tomorrow
we're going it's going to wipe like half
you know it's going to go in 1780
degrees centigrade apparently tomorrow
gotta love the uk if you don't like the
weather just wait an hour
but you know um
90 humidity i i haven't experienced that
for a very long time but i remember it
just we just swept constantly
awful um
but yeah so i absolutely adore that i've
met these amazing people and some of the
amazing people i do want to thank so
we've already seen that shelley's in the
house and she's saying hi shelley runs
our facebook account before shelley came
along and this is actually i stole
shelley from um i made steve who i used
to do um videos with on
um
uh mystery machine a lot and he still
has an amazing channel now um he has
been stranger times paranormal here you
go
um
he still has a great channel now he
talks about ghosts he does a lot of mud
larking which i still don't really know
what it is it seems to me that it's um
just looking for rubbish but he'll go to
his channel and he'll explain to you
better than i ever could um
you know so so he i i stole
him i stole shelly off him because
she's just amazing at the facebook we
went from having about 300 subscribers
on facebook to now over a thousand which
is again brilliant it helps drive the
channel there's it's a really nice
little community and so if you do go on
the facebook channel please i'm sure
you're all on there already um other
people and i obviously want to spend
thank spence and mike who i wouldn't
have started the channel without them it
was their idea basically and i again
stole it
um matt who does uzingen who is in said
july a little earlier um he does our
discord server and now he does a reddit
and again
he doesn't i don't give him any money he
doesn't get paid for it he does it just
because he likes to and he enjoys it um
he does you know advertise his own
channel he's got his own channel on
there as well which please go subscribe
to as well um but i i'm genuinely a
little bit humble but i really honored
that somebody would actually go out of
their way and give their time like
stormy he gives his time to me every
single week
um just to talk rubbish basically and
have a laugh and make a video with me
and i you know earn a little bit of
money off that he doesn't earn anything
um he just does it because he's got time
matt is exactly the same doesn't learn
anything he just does it because he
enjoys the content hopefully i hope you
enjoy the content matt
get in the game comments and tell us and
there's the
there we go he just gave me up like a
dirty sir
sorry i love you michelle and you've
done amazing and yeah raise canada
um
but
so and that's the facebook group so i
get into the chat and that's the
facebook group so
um
again these people they they give their
time to this channel and this community
and you know they don't get anything
really in return and i can't i can't say
how much i i'm just really happy about
that um dave from darius lives again
he's appeared on a few videos with us he
again he he's one of our members and um
he has done nothing but be supportive
i'd like to thank all of the members
actually that we've got um i'll run
through them quickly so jack plaxtor
paul uh cindy harris andrew another
andrew colonel old man elizabeth sigurd
noodle and christopher um
you've been members a lot of those
people have been members for six months
or more that's pretty much from the
beginning and they give me their
hard-earned money on a monthly basis and
how you know ridiculous is that
um
i i i just i just can't say thank you
enough and it does help me to keep going
because you know at times you get crappy
messages you get told i rubbish your
videos by some idiot
um
arkansas usa allen thank you very much
sir
um
love the news new star trek show
fantastic jack i'm really happy about
that um i haven't really seen a lot of
it yet but
so um
yeah and then actually one person i
wanted to really thank out at the moment
is gustavo because he had a horrible
accident recently he's always been
really supportive of the channel he was
he was really badly hurt he actually
messaged me um because i was wondering
where he'd gone he missed me so i'm
really sorry i've not been around so
much and i've had a really horrible and
but i mean properly nasty accident but
he actually designed
this
he designed the starting bit and again i
didn't ask him to he did it because he
liked the show and thought you know what
i i've he's got some skills and he could
do it i did put a bit of a shout out and
goes looks anybody wants to help the
channel please do you know if you've got
any skills you know i don't i'm no good
at reddit i'm no good at discord i'm no
good at starting credits and things i'm
just not technically minded like that
and if you can help me they'd be amazing
and he put his time and even then when i
kept
critiquing and saying oh can you do this
can you do that he was just like yeah no
bother and cracked on and got it done
and now we've got a brilliant start in
sequence i didn't even ask him to do an
outro he just did that anyway
um because he thought it needed one and
he's right we did need one and again
that's brilliant so i mean i love the
new the new logo it's it's on our merch
you can go to cydashtrek.com
um by merch so
please do again want more money the more
money i can earn the the more likely it
is that my wife will allow me to keep
doing it
ah
so um
jerry lehan is is talking about mars
okay
fine
um
so yeah gustavo did an amazing job and
again thank you so much so
10 000 subscribers in 10 months next the
world
um i generally
i genuinely
thought when i started
um because it did really well for a
little while i thought oh my god we
could get 5000 subscribers this year
that would be incredible and i smash
that
um and then i i do i can't help but
wonder how big the channel could get
it's definitely
more difficult now to get subscribers as
you get a little bit bigger but then you
never know the algorithm might kick in
and youtube might actually support me
for once that would be nice um but you
know
i think we've got such a brilliant
community i'm not that fussed you know
get over 10 000 what amazing milestone
what an amazing achievement i'm really
really proud of what i've done i'm
really proud of what everyone else has
done that's helped me
um but you know
ah
it's fantastic just thank you so so much
um blondie rapture sheets
fair enough
so i just wanted to come on i wanted to
thank everybody i wanted to talk a
little bit about like i said what how
why i started the channel um
the only reason i do i don't really do
it for money even though that does help
i don't do it because um
i like hearing the sound of my own voice
as people regularly tell me in the
comments i've got a hot awful voice
apparently i think some people are just
mean for fun um my favorite comment a
little bit
before was um
this guy's got a face for radio that's
just like i can't argue that
he's not wrong
so
oh um geek
send this put us put a link on
i uh i don't think i've subscribed so
let me subscribe um
you just obviously got a brilliant i'm
happy what sort of content are you doing
put it get into the comments that's what
sort of things you're up to and maybe
people are going from subscribe to you
uh that is the merge i do so i'm going
to be doing some more
um stuff i've done obviously stuff with
the with
the logo on and but i'm going to do some
stuff that you know it's a little easier
to wear um i would ask you to go over
there and though we're now going to
really push for stargate to return we
are going to become an army that um
amazon cannot ignore
and there is some t-shirts mugs cups and
things on central commonwealth if you go
to the um
sg or sgc uh listing and it's just a
very simple tease it just says we want
stargate stargate logo on it
and what we want to do is on the july
the 27th we're gonna do a live show and
we're gonna do a twitter storm and this
has worked before it's you know amazon
suckers for this sort of thing metadata
and you know if it gets to the top of
twitter might just give them a kick up
the ass to actually bring stargate back
but what i want to do is get people to
you know get the shirt to get the
t-shirt get the cup whatever take photos
of themselves and when they do the
twitter um
we want stargate um i don't make any
money off that i'm not doing it for
money um i've just set it up to try to
do another level and try to bring a bit
more oomph to the twitter storm
hopefully it'll work um i'd love to see
that cell you know really really sell
i've got self hundreds i don't you know
that would be amazing but um but let's
try and really really uh thank you
bowser you've been with us since the
beginning as well you came from you came
from uh
the uh brief history mystery channel so
that's the thing
i picked up one of the metal beverage
get that good in there
uh it really really does look nice
they're really nice those ones are so
well done that's great uh wine coolers i
think aren't they um
they seem good quality uh
you're an american jack right you should
come pretty quick in the uk it took
about two weeks for mine to come
um but the postage is only like three
quid which i thought was pretty
impressive really it was pretty good
seen this one from america um but it did
take about three weeks but uh about two
weeks sorry i should say but uh my i
ordered my
um
we want stargate t-shirt they post it
within two days of me ordering it um
and i'm hoping it'll be here by next
week
so fingers cross
ignore them your voice is fine you mean
sultry right
you do mean sultry
or you know it's just like
this is this is this is the voice you
want to go to go to bed listening to
right
probably not
i agree stephanie thank you very much
sir congratulations
that's a long one
shirley hey buzzer hey shirley
i originated stargate started 19 cents
native to me yes sir
um
thank you sci-fi fans i don't see i've
not seen your name pop up before that's
amazing i've ordered two pint glasses
yesterday
thank you very much different patterns
different designs i assume we've just
ordered two pine glasses
that is actually fantastic but what but
it is it is actually a it's you know
not a blue me
i'm not a bloody broomy look at the chin
please i'm not a button but i am pretty
close to birmingham
so
birmingham's about 30 minutes away so
it's not bad i'm telfer's a bit of a
weird where i i'm from telford
and telford is the birthplace of
industry it's whether if you ever google
it's where the iron bridge is the
world's first ever iron bridge so it's
actually i live in a town steeped in
history and um it was it's considered to
be one of the birthplaces of industry
um
and uh
it's a it's a mixed town but i actually
live in a little village just outside
telford now
um but we don't really have a much of an
accent we're stuck between sort of a
brummie accent and a bit of a or a bit
of a wolverhampton accent and then a
proper stokey accent which i can't do
but everyone calls each other duck
and i can't really do the accent before
so i'm not very good at accents um but
um
yeah or we've
kind of liverpool just up the road with
liverpool um but you know so we we i
don't have much of an accent the other
thing guys i am grew up i should have
got talent accents
adrian
um i'm in newport sir
so local boy um if ever you see us on
the street say hello
i do not say bot
i don't know but
um i what i do do
do do and what i do is i drop t d's
become our t's become d's
with me i'm quite lazy in my language
and but i actually think i have a slight
sometimes i have a slight american twang
to my accent because i watch way too
much american tv when i was a kid and i
can slip into when i do i've been to
america a couple of times now and every
time i go i slip into the accent really
quickly really easily and they think i'm
taking the piss
and i'm just like my mates just like
wiring me up like oh coffee you want a
coffee and they're just like
where are you from and it becomes this
bastardized stupid sounding weird half
american half thing accent
yeah
yeah agent drop us a message sometime i
go on the facebook account drop us a
message i'd love to sailor
um
there's a couple of swans
in there there's there's one in newport
there's a two in telford there's a few
swans
um but yeah one shoes up the road
and yes swans is one of those that's
like saying do you know the king's ed
there's loads of
uh one of my favorite
jokes is just to shout um say aluminium
at stormy say it
um or to um
we discuss football occasionally
the swan at fort and adrian does do
great food it is just up the road it did
shook for a while but it's open again
and they do a mean sunday dinner
this one at fort and lovely
i was there just a couple of weeks ago
um but yeah guys i'd say i
which we're just randomly talking there
so could please get in there whoa too
much room myself
i miss that too much room
i will keep just talking rubbish until i
get to the end
okay
but i didn't stir this very well so it's
mostly room at the bottom
i would love you guys to get some
comments tell me what sort of videos you
want to see in the next few weeks i'll
give you a bit of a rundown as you're
that the hardcore fans watching this i
don't expect to get many views on this
video but the hardcore fans so the
videos that are coming up soon
sunday with matt
and we're doing a review of season two
of stargate it's going to be a bit of a
mixed batch i think that's going to be a
bit controversial because i have some
quite strong views about season two and
i've watched it again recently and i was
um surprised that i have some strong
views about it
i have rumors about a sci-fi show from
the early 90s that might be making a
comeback
um i can tell you now that i've heard
rumors that firefly um if you're a
firefighter flan fan and won't be making
a comeback um or not anytime soon
because disney can't figure out how to
do it apparently they've written about
five scripts
and they're all rubbish
so um they've scrapped that idea and
they're going with something else
instead i'm not going to tell you what
it was but it was a show that only did
one season see if you can guess getting
something as soon as i guess
um
cheaper five pound a pint what
no way five pounds that's london prices
that's ridiculous
um
yeah so firefly
one of my favorite sci-fi shows um it's
it's it's only second stargate and i'm
just going to get cancelled but
apparently yeah the the disney people or
all the people of fox because obviously
fox still i think
they've written about five scripts
and done a bunch of concept art and also
to try to figure out how to reboot
firefly
and apparently it just keeps coming as
rubbish
they've just ever just it's just it's
just terrible they can't figure out how
to do it so it's just gone on the back
burner and they're not that they just
keep pushing them back
and so it's probably not going to happen
jerry it is i'm afraid
not far escape i've heard no rumors
about farscape returning and i to be
honest i don't think it would
um
but i say tell you what though babylon 5
game is going to be making a comeback
hopefully actually the last thing i
heard was bubbler fives at risk as well
um
i know the cw chief executive recently
said that it was still being in
development but apparently they've hit
some hurdles
um but hbo max wants it there so what
they're going to be doing is it'll be on
the cw
on wednesday and then hbo max on a
thursday is is what is the current plan
apparently but it's got a few problems
and it won't be till at least early next
year middle of next year
5.50 for a point of ipa in dundee
but that's scotland
is that just because i know dundee is
really wealthy because of that that's
where a lot of the oil comes in and the
gas from the north sea so it's quite it
is a very wealthy town do they just they
just checking prices up for
you know
what a nonsense
wow
um i think this is the problem sci-fi
fans um
i think they actually genuinely want to
do a good show
and i know um that um oh his name's gone
the guys who's doing all the star wars
his name's gonna play happy in the
marvel movies apparently he has been
involved and um when they've sort of
like asked him to like consult he's not
going to be anything to do the show
apparently but they've asked him
a chord into one source it's this is a
rumor that they asked him to consult and
he was one of the people who said this
is crap
uh it's not gonna work
um delorean is coming out with a new
model jack just to go in with this
sci-fi twist because ambassador did say
where i can get a target with laura in a
second ago they're doing an electric
delorean and i gotta admit it looks sexy
as hell
harvey's best bit of five pounder
bleeding pine i paid by three quid for a
point
just like that their maxim did kick in
then i spell three f-r-e-e three point
three quid for a point
um it's about frequent or three pound
fifty and four quid if you're buying
like a stella or something like that but
um yeah i mean frequent
uh a bottle of bud is like 350 which is
only really half a pint so that's like
seven pound a pint really um but i tend
to drink wood um so but that is
not saying anything else
john favreau yes sir john favreau
so apparently they did speak to john
favreau and he basically went this is
rubbish and um and that was one of the
reasons why they've described apparently
they've done it they've written five
pilots and they've all been rubbish
so yeah
free quid
um i
would love a blake 7 reboot but i've not
heard no rumors about it but uh
when i ask people
i'm i'm of an age where i didn't really
watch blake seven i never i've never
really watched the reboot i've watched a
couple of episodes
but i'm i'm not quite old enough i'm
afraid i'm just a just a young
whippersnapper
um but when i ask people on the channel
or on the community page or whatever
what show would you like to see rebooted
from back in the day
blake seven is always pretty much the
first one that people say um it's it's
tends to be that and people say i i
occasionally get like a proper
thunderbirds and rather than you know
kids version because actually i always
thought thunderbirds should be they
should be like doctor it should be like
four kids but also do a grown-up version
and they can show like seven o'clock on
a saturday night and it would i think
it'd be amazing that the storylines and
stuff they could make a proper grown-up
version of that and it would be
brilliant i wish they'd made a proper
grown up film instead of letting
jonathan frakes ruin it
um
but yeah
i'm an electric delorean i've got an
electric car
it
pulls
like no vehicle i've ever driven and
i've only got a relatively cheap small
electric car but it properly puts you
back in your seat when it goes
um that at a sports electric delorean
will take your face off i i would love
that
um i'm trying falling behind i would
love to see a hyperdrive i used i did
like hype drive actually that was a good
show
um
but then now it's not that somebody else
has already beaten to it
um if you don't check out the film
sci-fi museum in milton keynes i've been
there it's it is actually pretty cool
uh the style that i was there when they
had a star wars um
uh like exhibition
on uh not star wars uh doctor who
exhibition on years ago now and that was
that was really cool
um i watched it back in the day oh and i
was a lad
back in a day when i was a lab
sapphire and steel
who would they get to play um sapphire
sapphire stealing silent running
sound running was a good one
um
and here's another one so we're smashing
through now david stewart are welcome uh
we want space 1999. that was a cool show
see uh that was a that was a british
show right am i thinking of the right
show um a very early technicolor sort of
thing um
and it was um
that was one of those great shows that
was uh
just extreme but never quite got the
popularity of doctor who sort of thing
bond is based on adrenaline like coke
i don't know sorry no idea
um
i'm old because when it came in
i'm getting towards the one jerry
anderson 99 it was jerry henderson
wasn't it space 1999 what was the um
show he did after that that was more
recent space precinct
i quite like space precinct
i watched that and it was horrendously
expensive it was like it was a bbc show
that cost a million quid an episode
which now is nothing but back then was a
ridiculous amount of money for the bbc
to spend on a show and people got really
angry about it and it was pepsi was atv
it was a million quid show anyway um but
actually it was really cool it's a fun
show and it did quite well in america
um
but but yeah space space precinct was
quite a cool show i wouldn't mind that
coming back either and i love i love all
those sorts of shows that were just a
little bit a little bit silly you know
book rogers is making a comeback there
will be a movie
but it won't be bitty bitty bitty with
tweaky and the space that the one thing
that actually annoys me about that is i
want to see the thunder fighter because
i think that's one of those iconic
fighters
me and stormy are actually gonna do a
series of videos soon where we sort of
like look at proper
fighters from sci-fi and sort of compare
and say
because he actually has a history in
avionics
he's a pilot so we're going to sort of
like what's the realism but actually
which one is cool and you know like the
um
the fighter from that does the rose bud
maneuver
uh that film's going to be remade as
well
oh what was it called
he plays the computer game and it and
then he comes and they take him he has
to fight and everyone else dies and
uh oh somebody somebody will tell me
what the hell that's anyway the fighter
from that is really cool
um
so book rogers is going to be coming
back but it's going to be more based on
the comic book rather than the glen a
larson tv show so we're not going to see
um the thunder fighter we're not going
to see um anything else like that duck
dodge is in the 24th and half century if
that doesn't come back there's just
there's no there's no justice in the
world because that was actually
fantastic
um
the expanse
i do have news about the expanse
but that will be out on
tuesday i've just picked which video i'm
editing next there is expanse news
um so i will tell you about that on
tuesday
i'd never watched blake seven either so
blackstone was a great final ending i
had a long seat brick box on australia
and binge a great storyline and blake
seven is a bit like space nine night i
i'd like to say
i never i didn't really see it but i'm
gonna have to get brick boxes so i can
watch it but yeah
and war games is also making a comeback
it is
thank you sir
last starfighter so what was the name of
the ship
what was the name of the ship from the
last starfighter and what was the name
of the maneuver it was the rose
something when it
right a last starfighter is they've been
trying to make it for about 10 years
um a complete reboot it'll be a hard
reboot um there's another film as well
they're trying to make a hard reboot
ovens um and i i put this these two
films in the same um
[Music]
as the same back brackets is films that
do not need to be made
and it's um
the flight to the navigator
those special effects still stand up
today still actually looks pretty cool
that film if you ever watch if you ever
catch it on disney it's on disney plus
at the moment go watch it the special
effects look good still
um because it kept it simple you know
they kept it like um subtle special
effects it really worked
um you can see like the and the shiny
ones it's flying along and everything
reflecting on the bottom it's really
really clever special effects um but
the glass star fighter is just is the
same for me i don't think they need to
remake that film um but i suppose the
last starfighter the special effects
would be a massive improvement
um but they lose a lot but yeah both of
those films are um death was it death
blossom was it and yes the gun star
star blossom that sounds more like it's
star blossom
star boston or death blossom somebody
google it
um the gun star yeah i love that fighter
if you look at
most realistic fighters in sci-fi you're
getting me going on some subjectivity
we're going to do a series of videos on
but i think the the gun star
and the thunder fighter
and the um
the one from babylon 5
the crosswind they're the most realistic
sort of fighters star fury are the most
realistic sort of fighters in sci-fi i
think they're great
paul reuben's voice the ship well that's
amazing don't know
space command about spotted launcher oh
yeah
that was awful
um space camp
that was what it's called wasn't it
space camp they were all on camp like
summer camp at nasa and somehow they
managed to accidentally launch the um
the the shuttle and they're all on board
i suppose you know that was actually
made with nasa as well they actually got
really thick what was the sci-fi film
with lee mages where he was i don't
think this is a sci-fi film or a
disaster movie really but he was aboard
a new type of airliner
and it was like hypersonic and it
accidentally flew into space and they
couldn't then get back
somebody get on google and tell me what
the hell film that was called because i
remember watching that when i was a kid
and i was a hugely mages fan and i
cannot wait for the reboot six million
dollar the six billion dollar man reboot
if ever it gets made um either but lee
mages was one of my heroes when i was a
kid so yeah come on guys get into the
get into the comments what was the film
lee mages
aboard the plane
that got into space and they couldn't
get back down again that was a good
sci-fi movie
quarter mass wow
um the out limit is making another
comeback i believe it's going straight
to netflix
if i remember correct left top of my
head
um
the thing with
star flight one or is that what it was
called that doesn't ring a bell actually
but i'll i will trust you because i'm
assuming you google it but thank you
carl for telling us that
um
the robot felt sorry for the kid and
sent them into space
oh yeah that's right
the um the thing yeah yes that is right
that's why they anticipated you're right
the aliens drop ship looked really cool
but i always thought the way it folded
out in the middle was a bit weird in the
that's where like the body of the ship
was but big chunks used to like fold out
of it i also thought that looked wrong
to me
but um
i do remember jason of star command
i do remember that
um
sort of
cartoons back in the day were amazing my
kids all they watch is youtube that's
all they want to watch
um it's i mean i i had
um all the cartoon channels on sky i was
paying for it about like 15 pound a
month or something and i realized i was
the only one watching it
um so we got rid of it um but
when we were kids they had amazing shows
there was that show
um jason that it was um
oh what was it uh
they all had like plants there was like
thingies with plants
and he had like a tank thing and it had
a ball they got them to smash it and
then um the bad guy was like this plant
thing that they turned into a tank as
well jason and the something or others
that was a great cartoon and proper um
space ghost i love that show
um but that was a proper properly i
should have got my phone with me in
there and google these things while i'm
talking but that was it was i think it
was like jason and something
that was a great show i missed that
um
you know and and we had some brilliant
cartoons when we were kids if you fly
from the 80s in the 90s you know they're
just like wheel warriors real warriors
that was a great show
um
the i'm gonna yeah
joyce and the chase and the wheel
warriors
fantastic it was such a good show um
there were some brilliant ones and
weren't there back in the day you know
and obviously we've got thundercats and
he-man and all those shows that we we
still remember but there's some
brilliant ones that kind of been
forgotten um
the one were they all dressed up as
birds
i do know that one that will come back
to me in a second because um i googled
that little one ago i watched open
sequence not long on youtube just just
remember it was oh my god carl uk you're
a genius battle of the planets
what a brilliant show that was
absolutely fantastic right guys this is
only going to be a 10 minute video and
i've been talking for 40 minutes so
oh that was mostly wrong oh dude that's
all settled to the bottom
again i'm gonna like it and i'm gonna go
and watch the last episode of dexter
because i've been watching that recently
and i've really been looking forward to
watching the last episode so um five
mile xl5
that's one of those that's one of those
shows that i used to draw
the the fireball xl5 i did used to watch
that when i was a kid because i i
you know
i just loved it it was on a sunday
morning on bbc2 here in the uk um i
still love that
fantastic um but no thank you guys and
thank you for everybody that's helped
this channel i'm really amazed
that we've got to ten thousand and hey
let's see what's next eh um when we get
to 15 000 i will
have three or four of these first and
then come on so shelly kept saying she
wants to see me drunk
maybe i'll do it then uh
in the meantime
please everybody stay safe look after
yourselves
um
just just generally humbly thank you
very much um
get in the comments on the video later
and tell me what sort of videos you want
in the future um i do think that this is
like a community
it's not just me doing whatever i want
i want you guys to come talk to me if
you want to come on a video and talk to
me about crap
just message me um i'm on the facebook
channel all the time you can im me um i
would love for you guys to come on and
and and and challenge me particularly
you know if you don't agree with me on
something
i love that i've got a reasonably open
mind um i i will either explain to you
why why you're wrong or i will
you know take it on the chin if i if i'm
the one that's wrong
and it never happens that's the wife i'm
never wrong um
um but you know so i i i seriously would
love you guys to come and join me on
here anytime you like um this is a
community
and i'm just really really
really proud to hit 10 000 subscribers
it was a nice thing to wake up to this
morning
so
thank you so so much and i will see you
on sunday
for um a live show
swinging from the chandelier
and
again congrats see you next time drunk
well done the 10 000.
go enjoy your thing axi thank you guys
so much here's to 20 000 let's not get
ahead of ourselves
good night guys i will see you all very
very soon actually it's sunday at six to
look at stargate and i might do a little
quick video tomorrow as well you never
know
can i guess